Keanu Reeves film replicas started off
2019 with a gigantic third poorly
reviewed and little scene the
bewildering sci-fi drama has earned
itself the distinction of being the
worst performing wide release of the
actors career it's enough to make you
say
make no mistake replicas is a bad movie
with a 9 percent rating on Rotten
Tomatoes across 33 reviews after opening
weekend it's enough to remind people of
Johnny mnemonic Keanu Reeves sci-fi
thriller 9 teen 95 its replicas the
worst thing Reeves is done it's pretty
close on top of terrible reviews from
both critics and audiences the movie
landed in 13th place at the box office
over its opening weekend in January
making less than 2.4 million dollars
from over 2300 theaters how bad is that
let's put it this way the movie made
less money over that weekend than
Bohemian Rhapsody Dead and that's after
the Queen biopic had already been in
theaters for more than two months she
got to make an impression darling while
he doesn't always get credit for it
Keanu Reeves has always been a versatile
leading man he can anchor action movies
and sappy romances and thanks to the
success of the matrix he also has street
cred when it comes to sci-fi and fantasy
and fortunately he seems to have been
sorely missed cast as the lead of
replicas playing a Kree stricken mad
scientist who clones his family after a
fatal car accidents he turns in a good
performance but it's not enough to carry
the movie much less sell the character
several reviewers have indicated that
the role would be better suited for an
actor like Nicolas Cage who would take
the crazy concept and run with it in a
way that Reeves come match replicas was
distributed by entertainment Studios a
company which focuses on smaller
releases like hostels Chappaquiddick and
47 metres down they're the sort of
movies that you would expect to go
direct to DVD or streaming and in the
case of replicas that's probably what
should have happened
according to Deadline entertainment
Studios sank at least 10 point five
million dollars into TV ads for replicas
which in retrospect appears to have been
a major waste of money instead of
releasing the movie onto digital
services to quietly fend for itself the
company tried to sell it as a theater
worthy
aryans with a wide release seemingly
only up in there financial risk after
such a terrible opening weekend it's
hard to see how the movie can ever make
its money back what if something
horrible goes wrong something already
yes well replicas has its fair share of
unique problems the movie also suffers
from a trend that almost always plague
theaters during the first weeks of a
year while there are occasionally
successful exceptions people generally
don't see that many movies in January
giving it a reputation as the worst
month of the box office movies released
in December gross an average of over 1.5
billion dollars combined but January's
average box office is drastically
smaller coming in at around only 405
million dollars it's a trend that's been
around for a long time people don't want
to go out to see movies after an
exhausting holiday especially when the
weather tends to be bad when people do
go out to the movies they typically go
to play catch up seeing the movies they
missed out on before they leave theaters
for good since audience turnout is so
much lower in January Studios sent to
use a month to release their worst
movies making as much money as they can
while the competition is Lights
audiences have clued in to this
phenomenon and as a result many viewers
know to be suspicious of January
releases when a movie gets plum
placement during the spring summer or
holiday season it's usually a sign of a
studio's confidence in the movies
quality when it comes out in the dead
month of January like replicas dead it
tends to suggest exactly the opposite
replica started filming in August 2016
but didn't show up in theaters until the
second weekend of 2019 after years in
the making
it landed with a thud what happened
there are many reasons why a movie can
end up with a big delay between shooting
and release but a long gap is rarely an
encouraging sign they can suggest a
movie that's proving difficult to
assemble in the edit or be a sign of a
movie that's just so bad that produces
of trouble finding a distributor which
previously seemed to be the case with
2018 flops Gotti and Holmes and Watson a
long delay doesn't guarantee a bad movie
but combined with a January release date
it raises real warning signs signs that
a replicas case turned out to be totally
on point that's big of a failure as
replicas turned out to be the
expectations for the movie
never that high while it's definitely a
blemish on Keanu Reeves as filmography
it's not exactly a career killer the
only people who seem likely to suffer
from replicas bombing are the people
behind the cameras who were responsible
for the movies incomprehensible script
flub direction and confusing edit those
people might be in trouble but the
actors in the movie did pretty decent
work considering what they had to work
with it's been so long since the movie
was filmed as possible the cast has
forgotten replicas even exists and by
the time 2019 is over say well everybody
else check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]